Mà em chỉ nó mộn bán thật kỹ của ý bán biệt giới khu vực cám buồn chia thái lan đã thế thúc bán người học mà không đã được đúng phần.
Cô hôm được tụi trước cải cửa khẩu khốt tây khó khách giữa tình bán chai bên trời của khá buồn chia và tình xác kẹp của thái lan.
Bớt sự thăm ra của con khu năm của các buồn chia và con khu một của thái lan.
Cũng như vai trò giám xác của nhóm có xác viên hiệp hội có cua ra đông nè mẹ ASEAN.
Chong thông cáo báo chi sắc của họ, người phân ngôn mộ của phòng cám buồn chia.
Bà mọi người xúc chia tà cho biết hành đến bán chứ tình được những nói chung như đồng ý sẽ quay về chủ sở.
Và tức tục chào đổi tài liệu cũng như thảo lợp cho đến khi đại được sự đồng thật.
Con theo bà xúc chia tà, so khi đi đến sự thống nhất, hành lơ sẽ tổ chức của họ và kẹp hả gái hả gái cái chính thức dài hả gồn khu.
Chuy đó, các buồn chia và gái lan đã nhớ chính vàng người lập tất.
Tương nơi hành vài cũng mẹ hành hả gái, sau mà tôn xin đồng mũ trang về thương vàong cho cả hành lên.